okay hello everyone we are continuing
our season of design reviews for version
13.1 of language
and we are looking at
well
it doesn't really discrete computation
but it's graphics and geometry and so on
i think we've gotten through effects and
shading and we're now on to filling
correct
right
i don't know whether i mean
i wouldn't de-experimentalize pattern
filling yet
i mean i think it's fine but i don't
know how much it's been used yet
i mean i haven't used it yet ever
i kind of forgot it existed there's some
things i might have used it for but i
haven't used it yet
do do we know of uses
um okay then they are if they are then
then that's not the experiment like that
okay well we have well the proposal was
that we haven't heard any complaint but
yes that's not a good answer that's
let's leave it experimental okay i think
it's i think it's a slightly
complicated story here that is
you know
has yet to mature
you know i'll be more convinced if i've
used it three times but i haven't yet
even though i i really had forgotten
existed and i could have probably used
it for some things
um
okay let's let's move on if there's no
okay region reconstruction
reconstruction mesh
okay so this is what we discussed
some previous time in terms of naming
um
so this is given a bunch of points
this is produce a mesh that that somehow
interpolates those points correct that
is not just a you know
like a specifically a concave hull mesh
but it's something more elaborate is
that right
yes
so for example if i were to take
um
okay so the random points and that's
reconstructing the annulus for the
random points that's nice it's really
quite nice
yeah great
okay
any more to say about this function
hey wake up guys this morning no no no
no i mean this so this is intended to be
the
the top level the most automated thing
right yeah it recognizes different
dimension
meshes
so you can recognize a curve
reconstruct a curve or a surface or a
volume i understand okay it's nice it's
really a nice thing it seems like a good
i mean
you know we can obviously try uh you
know basically the the and by the way it
should definitely point to random point
i would think
which is sort of the inverse of
reconstruction mesh
yes and random point should point to it
yes
um
and just for my amusement i mean and you
know if i were to make
a
you know random real
uh
you know 10
you know 102 or something and i would
just to say reconstruction mesh of this
it should reconstruct a um basically a
rectangle
nice
it's really nice and then and then if i
wanted to i could say some how would i
get the boundary of this
boundary mesh
uh
no re region bounce
no no no no i want the actual boundary
points here
oh i want the i want this spin
i see
okay
okay cool so i could then say something
like
nice okay
for either one of them yeah sure it's an
approximation to 100.
yes
okay
great stuff all right gradient fitting
mesh
okay this is a more specialized mesh
type right
yes
which could be used by reconstruction
mesh yes or no
yes yes this is poisson method
why on earth does it not point to
reconstruction mesh here
we will update it we i mean we are still
finishing the documentation doing the
deep linking and such so it's still
impossible okay all right okay fine
all right
so
i don't understand at the normals at
those points how does it know what the
normals i don't understand does it
is gradient fits the best
i don't understand how does it know the
normals at these points
so you give the you give the normal if
you don't give the normal there is
actually a new function where we
actually estimate the normal by
computing the k nearest neighbor
i think that's one of the automation
actually which is added to those
functions okay but i understand but this
thing here p1 p2 p3 those are points of
this form is that correct
yes
so i mean you should make it clearer
here that those are not just coordinates
which is what i would have assumed
they work with coordinate we take
coordinates across the point i mean
there is that whole stuff in geometry
that we avoid you know explicitly
forcing people to use point rapper i see
okay fine but if you just give the
points then you have to estimate the
normals using your technique is that
correct
yes
but you don't say that here
you don't say that here or estimate it i
see okay fine time for fine yes you do
okay
cool
so and this is i mean if i did this in
2d for example what would it do
this one doesn't yet work in 2d it will
but it's not
okay all right
so i mean if i gave it this thing if i
gave it if i said
um
splash oh i see it doesn't work in 2d so
if i have to i have to give it like like
points in 3d
that's rather nice
kind of a cool way of getting a random i
mean i don't know what what other ways
are there of getting some kind of
randomized surface like this
it's kind of interesting
at least in each example or something
do you understand what this just did
yeah you you're doing a bunch of
interior point but this one
doesn't this one um
so
i mean it's set up for random point in
in this case we you know
we are pretty much you know trying to
estimate the surface and hopefully that
will be close right so
yeah
but i understand but you're estimating
the surface normals
by you're effectively getting some local
continuity of the surface because you're
estimating surface normals from
neighboring points
and so there's presumably a coherence
length that i can define somewhere
um
yes it's not directly on this function
but yes
okay
what's new here
the dimensions
so earlier you know this function was
returning d minus one dimension based on
embedding dimensions now you can ask
acts you know the specific cells
dimensions so maybe you want
zero
or 3d
so so in other words you're saying
if i want just the
i want i want a bunch of planar facets
interpolating through this thing here
right
yes so i mean if i rather than if i just
say concave hole mesh
what's the alpha parameter that that's
that's some kind of
um that's the the radius of the ball
it's kind of a closeness
what does that mean why did it do that
okay there we go so that is a
that is a d minus one dimensional so
that's a surface fitted through those
points correct right
but if i now were to say comma one here
i would get oh that's very cool
lovely
these are nice
okay where am i storing this stuff
uh
where am i storing this anybody know
written crafts please
okay
okay
estimated point normals okay that's the
function you were just talking about
yes
i see
so it's just going to return a bunch of
normal vectors for these points
yes
vertices of that mesh so what does it do
when it okay so so if i
so i don't quite understand how i make
use of this thing so if i say estimated
point normals
um
god i hate the way that you do this with
pts equals and then pts inhibitor
whatever that's okay it's all right it's
not as bad as it might be
okay yeah because this is this is what i
was wondering about is how do you make
you solve
so
i mean in most uses of this you're going
to want to
uh
you know thread this into the thing that
you're dealing with right
am i making sense
you're going to need to
why to
white to attach the normal to the point
yes
but there are other uses steven you
might have a graphics complex
you know
um that you want to add uh you know
surface normals too
i i understand that but in all of these
cases what you're basically doing is
sprinkling surface normals
into a structure that already exists
correct in other words what you really
want
is not it's more like
uh i mean i don't think this is
necessarily the right i think that this
is a low-level function i think that
we've provided sort of low-level
programmer interfaces too
you know you don't need it we
automatically do it for you i think okay
in these other cases no but i'm just
hanging out for just one second i mean
the the main issue is this is you want
to insert into existing data structures
the normals
okay so what i'm wondering is is the
right function a thing that contains a
function
or at least can optionally contain a
function that instead of returning the
normals here it returns effectively
the normals you know knitted according
to some function
did you understand what i'm saying
um yeah but i don't i mean we have to
know i mean so that won't be complete
but we need we can enumerate some of the
use cases so you just mentioned one
which is point there could be another
one which is polygon there can be
another one that's polyhedron there can
be another one
so what i'm suggesting is but but i
don't think that those even enumerate
all the cases because you know when we
provide low-level programming primitives
which are viewed as as being
then
we we don't you know that's the point of
it we don't anticipate all use cases no
i understand roger i'm just trying to
say that in a case like this right what
you actually want is to inject vertex
normal options into those points
right
yes
and estimated point normals
and the right way to do this point is to
use multi-point and then you have a list
of normal so it's not a hard thing to do
i see it unless you use this point fair
point fair point okay and the same apply
also for mesh that's why you see we're
adding the second argument there where
you can give the mesh and then we return
you the
the normal based on your ordering of
your vertex coordinates so you just map
it directly
so how do you put
okay so the the point is
that so in this case here
i mean i understand the point of this
function i'm just saying i i okay hold
on
let's take this as an example okay
there's the multi-point thing etc etc
etc and now it's just going to return
for me
the you know just the list of normals
but i don't quite understand
you know maybe it's a different function
but maybe it's not useful i don't know
you know insert estimated point normals
basically
that is take the data structure that you
have
and
spray that in that's something that's an
operation we have not done very often i
mean we could imagine
for example for a graph
it's something where
we normally don't do that like it's not
the case that you know let's say the
chromatic number of a graph
um or the i don't know the the
okay for graphs what we're doing is
similar to what you're doing here that
is
okay you you know the um
uh
you know the list of vertices vertex
list
and if you want to know the i don't know
uh
vertex out degree or something you
vertex out degree of the graph just
gives you that list in the order of the
vertex
list if you if i'm making sense sure
right and this is the same type of thing
yes
right
and so i'm kind of unmaking my own
argument to some extent
that this is
and
this is like
vertex out degree
applied to a graph this is estimated
point normals applied to a mesh
just returns in the order of the mesh
points which you can extract from a
property from the mesh yes returns these
things
yes
okay
okay i'm not objecting
okay um
sander is asking for 3d does it give
normals versus points edges or faces
for points edges and faces
uh so the method we are using is a you
know thin fitted like written there
essentially we are using the
hyper plane
so if it's in 3d we are going to use
pretty much try to
pickpoint or estimate the plane
on that
d minus one dimension but he has a point
but i i mean we could consider that so
if you have let's say a polyhedron or
mesh
you you could attach a normal to an edge
i mean so to the corner point which this
one does or you could attach a normal to
an edge or to a face
all of which is possible
well you can attach information
i mean it depends on how you interpret
it right
i mean i didn't say i didn't mean attach
as in attach within annotation i mean
that you can compute it there is a
well-defined normal for an edge
you start to get into graveyard even in
this case right because then you get
into the you know weighted normals and
then there is a different way to weight
the normal how you apply it so that's
why we are trying to extend it later on
with several methods and you know
then we can cover you know any way
people want to to compute normals right
um okay but
why didn't this work
oh we are still implementing it's called
okay but it will work
yes
so if you do i think if you do mesh
coordinator on that it may probably work
this thing mesh coordinates
yes
and i assume these are unit normal
vectors is that correct
yes this should be
okay so i mean if i if i were to do this
as a um
i don't know how to
wait a minute i see that's at the points
of the polyhedron so i would have to
transpose this in to make my to make a
to make the hedgehog
so to speak
to make the outgoing arrows right
okay let's come back to sanders point um
which is right now we have got
a
for a given mesh
we are only taking its points as the
places for which to generate normals
right but i think sanders point is
that you could perfectly well like for
the stodahedron
why are we taking the oscars it's called
estimated point normals
right you could have it equally well
have a thing estimated face normals
if you knew what the faces were
yes
okay i mean you don't even need to
estimate them
well in the case with dodohedron you
know what they are yes
i mean if it's a mesh
polyhedron there's like no estimation
it's
it is what it is
but what i pointed out is that they are
not actually unique on the face too
right what
i mean there are two of them you mean
well the normal on the face you're
assuming this is distance right the same
as we do on graphics you can you know
build the normal based on the weight of
the
vertices
this civil version is kind of what i
mean
so it's not just one
one standard way to compute the normal
for a face
i don't know to me the the norm the face
pretty much has one normal there's no
okay so play in our face
it has one normal one
i mean but there might i don't know what
use case you're thinking of but it's
kind of if you want to round them out or
something well wait a second i mean
there's also crazy faces like like um
uh ones where the thing is not
you know specified in some kind of weird
bow tie type thing and it's not plainer
given the points but those are not
really faces that's like
yeah that's
i'm talking about the guess like the
gross shading right the the first normal
i still i
yes what are you saying though
well there we go we get uh you know we
get corner normals vertex normals
and
for guru shading we then compute colors
in the corners and then those are
interpolated across i see
um craig on that live stream is is
saying this is going to be very useful
um and it's also saying be nice to be
able to interpolate normals at any point
on a mesh
that is what you're doing here is you're
delivering given the points
you're delivering
what the normal is estimated at that
point but i think what creativity is not
a it's not a bad idea
right so in other words it's a function
where it's it's
specified
well you basically are giving point on
the map it's like an okay so here look
it's like interpolation right i mean
you're basically oh no you have to kind
of do a closest point or something
because there's no coordinate system on
the mesh
um why isn't there i don't understand
that i don't understand
what what you oh i see what you're
saying you're saying you don't know
these are points which are guaranteed to
be on the mesh
well they are attached to the corners
yeah yeah this these points here are
guaranteed to be on the mesh
right so if i do for example here i say
uh reconstruction mesh of this
what's it gonna do
oh dear
that does not look much like a
dodecahedron to me
well you you use the
uh
yeah currently the method is kind of
white especially i mean the method we
currently have we are trying to assume
that
the surface you want to rebuild is
smooth right
and search and close so
okay so we lost some what what happened
here
by the way you should put this in a
possible issues thing
in the in reconstruction mesh
okay what happened here to my dota k
john
i got one nice pentagon there but what
else happened
um well we try to reconstruct it from
the object so we
unfortunately there's no full guarantee
that will recover everything
if you just sprinkle so we need we need
more data right so if you get more
points the the robustness goes up so you
can do random points let's say the
boundary region for decay hatred
do sample the boundary not the interior
so you get the surface
so what how do i do that boundary
right
region boundary right
boundary region yeah region boundary
decay here
and now
sample
yeah and now i say reconstruction mesh
of this it will still look smooth
probably but less
uh what's going on here
why did does it surprise you it's taking
so long
that's pretty good
nice
okay so now what i'm saying is
let's see
what you're saying is
if i state just a random i mean okay so
here's what you could imagine you could
imagine a normal field so to speak that
is a feel and a vector field
at every point even in space
there's an interpolating vector field
of what the normal direction would be if
the mesh
you know
were to go through that point in space
yes that's that's a cent but then the
question of whether
you know how you get to the point that's
actually on the mesh
that is near the point that you're
specifying is not so obvious you might
drop towards you know i don't know what
you want to do go towards the centroid
or something oh you could do the nearest
point for instance if you want to do
that yeah i see the nearest point on the
like region nearest yeah
yes
well it does seem like a i mean an
interesting
like it's a good wfr function to start
off with
to find the interpolated given a mesh
and given a point
what is the
interpolated normal
you know for that point that isn't one
of the actual points on the mesh
something sense
yes that's what we're talking about
right yeah
i mean it'd be interesting to know what
some use cases are whether that's a
thing that we should be thinking about
as an extension to this
estimated point normal thing well it
would be interesting to hear from that
user what uses
um
all right let's move on but that's
that's interesting and at least
a good wfr possibility
okay mesh
region supported polyhedron cells what
does he what do you mean by that
so we had special for 3d we supported
things like simplex
and hexahedron
but four special cells that can be
supported in 3d
now it works for any polyhedral cells
so you mean i can extract dodecahedra
out of some random collection of points
no no a mesh region is built up with
cells yeah okay
i'm saying so you have to specify all
the cells
so like in 2d you can have any polygon
as a cell
i see do you understand yeah no this is
the analog in 3d that we can have any
polyhedron as a cell but they may not
tessellate space well then it's
well no but yes but then
you have a weird mesh region
yes okay fine mesh region allows for
that flexibility
but so simplexes
you're saying you're generalizing from a
simplex to an arbitrary number of faces
on the polyhedron yes
okay fair enough so so you have
honeycombs and other things
you know and and voronoi mesh is an
example of that
okay are you telling me that we finally
have 3d yes yes yes oh my gosh how do
you realize people have been asking for
that for 20 years
and we have to apologize every time that
we don't have it okay show me a 3d
voronoi this is this is exciting hold on
hold on a second i got to do this myself
okay so random point let's say 10
uh
30 comma 3 you want condom
that's what i want yes thank you
um okay and now i say varnoi mesh
oh my gosh
look at that
and now so can i can i if i show this
with um can i show this with opacity
yes uh you don't measure or your
adoption or mess with john
why should i do region plot with some
opacity
oh no well you can't do it but i cannot
guarantee that you will work correctly
no why wouldn't this work
no
we we still have to work on region plot
understand it it won't it won't work
well it's a 2d plotting function to
begin with but you know but even that
i mean the purpose of vision plot at the
time was not
okay right i think this should work i
mean this is that's the correct region
you just saw it it just doesn't show
your partition which you probably want
to see i feel so dude if you do a mesh
with john and then uh
you could do it directly in the voronoi
mesh too
okay all right okay
go ahead what do i want to say here um
for example base style goes to
opacity
magnificent
boy people have been waiting a long time
for this
why was it so hard
because he was
i'll go ahead what it was never been
hard because people have been asking for
this for 20 years i mean the key thing
is that we need to we needed that
support of police don't sell in mesh
region
that's the key thing so we need to be
able to compute on it beside just you
know looking at them right looking at it
okay so for example let's say i want to
take this thing and i want to shatter it
and i just want to have all those
separate polyhedra all those cells
okay
how you use the mesh which dimension you
know you probably want the
um dimensional cells
how do i visualize those
use mesh primitives yeah use mesh
primitives because then you get the
coordinates stuck in there directly how
do i do that mesh primitives instead of
my cells
actually you know no no here's what he
should do charles he should just get
mesh coordinates karma mesh primitives
i sort of mesh cells that's the
efficient way to do it
this thing here no so do
graphics complex you can do graphic
complex mesh coordinates
yes
that's the efficient way to do it
if you want to look at it no actually
that will just show them again there's
no point that's not i i want to i want
to see the things look
i i i know do back i'm backing off let's
do mesh primitives and just wrap
graphics around it
or or you know
just comma three yeah
map graphics around the map graphics
onto the whole thing graphics 3d yeah
graphics 3d
there they are okay nice
by the way you should use that as an
example i mean not maybe one with this
many but
that's really cool
and whatever you want to compute on
those primitives you know like the areas
or sorry volumes and centroids and other
things
right so what i could do here is i could
say something like volume
of volume slash at mesh primitives of
that
and then i could say
histogram of those volumes and i could
see how well it managed to get them to
be equal volume
yeah
this is exciting this is so long you
know
yeah
it's just like i i learned i was been
writing this history of the nks book and
and whenever you see in a book
description this long awaited work from
so and so it means the author was ten
years late in delivering the book
so this is a the long awaited function
3d paranoi
never mind
it's really great we have this okay
um
all right onward
uh
integrate
okay go ahead
well we it's not in the prototype build
right now but it's as well you know the
example is there we you know we're
standing it and making it more you know
improving the performance and robotness
so what was not i was surprised that
doesn't that didn't work previously this
thing here well it did work but it was
not using um i mean we haven't really
fully derived
the closed form formula i see i see so n
integrate would work the syntax would
work but the the formula would not have
worked right so we derived you know like
we've derived
uh and very efficient sort of polynomial
integrators over all special regions
okay okay what kinds of functions do
they involve
well it varies um this one
turns out to be what p is
yeah
okay so they're typically hypergeometric
family type things well some of them are
polynomial if you integrate the simplex
polynomials over simplex it's polynomial
okay
and um yeah but i mean you've got these
quadratic gammas
right but these these are fundamentally
regions defined by quadratic constraints
are they not yeah this one gets fourth
order though
okay but i mean given that quadratic
that the constraints are quadratic does
that what does that tell you about what
functions will be involved in
representing
i think source is not quadratic it's
it's cubic
how is it
yeah okay
well it's cool with cylinder and ball
and so on are quadratic obviously
okay regions with parameters
non-constant regions what does that mean
oh you mean you mean that i can put a
parameter into this taurus
i can say taurus
i think this means generally we've
improved our capability of integrating
and dealing with parameters
in regions yes we can we've always been
able to have parameters in regions but
it's probably been improved right now
the symbolic site
of it
okay
infinite line through
so we've had line through for a while
correct
no we have infinite line and these are
coming from the
michael team synthetic geometry
they're used in in the opposite way
they're used to provide constraints
because if you have more than two points
there's no guaranteeing that they are in
a line at all
yeah so so
they in there they're used in the
opposite way they say these are on a
line
okay so what does it do you know i
understand but what happens if i give
non colonial points
it returns on evaluation
okay
i
do we have somebody from that team here
no
okay so i want to look at this with
those guys
can we either find somebody from that
team because i don't really understand
this
i mean you know when we say circle
through for example you know if i say
for example
if i give it a bunch of points right and
i say
something like i mean again if we can
find somebody from that team that'll be
great
right now um
if i say this right and i say circle
through
it have to be 2d first
thank you
oops
who would you like for that team to join
i don't know you have to ping michael
and ask him who's relevant
okay so if i now do this with four
points
it's going to say no luck
well it's it's depend right so we we use
the first three point and if you manage
to check that the fourth point is on the
curve then we return it
i understand
but so
let's look at the documentation for
circle through
huh
okay
so you're doing something directly
analogous to that
yes
all right let's get somebody from that
team let's ask about this for a minute
okay because i don't fully understand
how this is used
and i don't see why this one doesn't
have examples of that
well i got equally confused that you did
just as you did now stephen
until i realized that that's the use
case is to provide a constraint to
success
let's get somebody from that team and
let's hear about how that works
and so i think they were incorrectly
documented actually
sorry i disagree i mean there is two
things right synthetic geometry want a
representation and then there is the
analytic part right so this function
covers both
okay let's get somebody from that team
let's discuss it when they're here okay
let's keep going
no i started thinking about sac does it
use least squares does it fit
right it doesn't do guys guys stop let's
get somebody from that team
okay um okay
geodesic polyhedron
okay we just talked about this yesterday
a bit
um
so i don't understand if i if i can say
geodesic polyhedron
what's the difference between this and a
and a you know and a communal garden
bucky ball
is that in fact a bucky ball
no the bucket ball generate
excitement faces this one are more
triangles
and it's more a kind of a subdivision an
approximation of a sphere
okay so i understand so this is this is
when i say three here
this is
a um uh this is the decomposition n
times
your subdividing end times here is that
correct
let's let's be very basic
splaferoo why doesn't that work
what should that do you're subdividing
here
what is the base case the zero case that
one is the base case
we never index stuff with starting with
zero in principle
no i understand that but what would be
um
sandra's asking is this convex whole
mesh of sphere points of n
no it's
not right because sphere points
is a different is yet a different thing
although that's a very good example
of um
i mean sphere points will will attempt
to equally space points on a sphere
and so that will produce for you a much
less regular looking object
he says what the heck
michael trott is here hello i just
joined
what the heck is this
that's the most symmetric object you can
make with 20 points
oh yeah so it is right let's but let's
do 25 points that's more interesting
oh
lovely we could have made those 25th
anniversary spikeys right from this
probably
that's cool
okay so this is a hundred faced okay so
it's interesting to compare that with
this
and by the way you really that this
should be both an example in sphere
points and an example i think in convex
hull mesh good idea
um but but in this case i'm just trying
to understand the subdivision number
here
means what
one subdivision is this one subdivision
charles
roger
no this is good this is the original in
this case is the high cosine
so if i go to two i will take every face
of this and subdivide is that correct
um yes
okay um okay the question that we had
for michael is has to do with infinite
line through yep
okay
and we want to understand what
uh
explain the use case in geometric scene
basically a line in our world is can go
back forth left right we want something
that is
a line in the classical sense with
points ordered along it
okay
but michael
my understanding is that you use it to
constrain it if i give you three points
with probability one they're not going
to be unaligned but you support the you
know three or any number of points so it
doesn't even make any sense in general
unless you say that you approximate them
to a line
but you have a co-linear you have
something that says collinear what is
collinear points called linear points is
the condition whether the points are
covalently right
okay so now what is infinite line
through relative to collinear points
the lines the other ones are points
that's the actual line the constructor
right
collinear point as the name says is a
set of points
and yes
but i okay so look but then it makes no
sense to support arbitrarily many points
they're never going to be on the line
no but but what do you mean by this like
you you you state that they are on the
line that's what i was just telling you
right
as a constraint
well or alternatively okay so look
infinite line through
abc basically where these are
so so if i do this if i say
something like um geometric scene
of a b
if i could spell um
of abc
right it doesn't work right now but yes
this is exactly the case
okay and then i say random instance of
this exactly right then we the only
thing we were using different vocabulary
to describe the same thing right but the
main point is this is then a symbolic
the most interesting use case of this is
a symbolic use case not a concrete use
case which is not what's documented here
at all and it's just totally confused
no no it's not confused we are writing
the example it's written in the details
we are not confused is written in the
data we are updating the documentation
we are waiting on examples is not the
final version in terms of examples okay
but but
the only key thing is that on the usage
we could have said
the infinite
line two represent an infinite line we
chose to say give an infinite line so
it's a lot of jobs yeah right which is
not though it's making roger and me at
least very confused
but the next line we are just at it we
see it's typically you know used to
specify the questions but i think you
should reword the thing at the top to
make it clearer okay this says
represents a circle which is much
clearer
right that's what you should do here
represents an infinite line going
through these points
now why michael why didn't this work
because
this one
this one here would circle through
this is a good question
okay it should work i'm not sure right
now
but then what that should do is
it
i mean
right i mean i should be able to ask the
question given that there's a circle
through a b and c
what is the angle between you know what
is the angle abc or something
right
how would i ask that question
assume there's a circle through a b and
c what is the angle you know
once you get your points out you can do
that right yes
i don't think you can answer this in one
one get go
okay
okay but i mean that's a reasoning thing
that one should potentially be able to
ask
symbolically is if i say if i assert
that there is a circle through a b and c
then i should be able to say you know
what is that what is the function that
gives me an angle uh
english
okay so i'm here
this is very much not unique at all i
mean
like
they're infinitely many
triples of points and circles
yes
right but different angles right yes
although
right but anyway okay i understand so i
think there's a little bit of
re-documentation needed here an arc
through
is what is the difference between arc
through and circle through
it's not a full circle right it's a
circular arc maybe it should be called
circle or arc actually because it's not
a general arc it's a circular arc right
yeah
i think so
do we have the notion of a circular arc
i mean we don't have a circular arc
primitive no circle has it built in i
know that since 30 years ago yeah right
although how do you specify the arc in
the case of arc through here how are you
specifying the arc is it specified using
a circle specification or what's the
no so this auto evaluation so this is
actually useful the auto evaluation when
applicable it converts it to a circle
primitive right that is useful
right
so we have more of these things
uh circum circle and and so on do that
they they basically order evaluate
i think the circus rule you just write
that didn't work the second argument has
to be a list not the whole primitive it
works just fine
okay that's just a minor baguette
i mean it probably shouldn't need to be
a
lovely
i mean you should fix the baguette okay
okay yeah that's good
uh that's lovely
okay
nicely spaced
we put a reasonable amount of effort
over the last weeks that might so this
okay it's still not still some things to
be done but good much better
why do you have to have a thumb here
rather than this being the overall
why why is this not the overall outer
what's it there or something i i don't
remember right now what was the least
this is pretty fancy i haven't seen this
before
wow i'm pretty sure you did we had a
couple meetings about it
that's lovely
um
yeah okay
all right so this
what do you think circular arc through
i think it probably should say circular
arc through
agreed
yes no i think that's the better name we
have a bunch of other arcs
yeah even though and the objection to
changing this to circular arc through
should it be then
segment
circus circle segment
why isn't it called circular arc isn't
that what it's called and that's what it
says here isn't it
i mean that's what it calls itself
right
right it says circular arc so unless
that is wrong this thing should call
itself circular arc through
sure i mean it's fine
no objection all right so let's move on
okay i think that's what we needed
michael for okay let me go back to my
other meeting thanks a lot thank you bye
bye spatial point data
oh that was the bug that i had found yes
um yeah i think so
it was one of the workflow things
now supported by all geometric functions
so what explain i i was doing that
elephant thing right
what was the so what did i have i had a
bunch of geo i can't remember what you
did but
but the workflow thing should should
work you know that this is another
collection of points that's come
okay so for example if i say
something like um
and then i say
oh
what
well this is this is not what we were
talking about here but what
what on earth is happening here
well
the first the first line tell you right
we have the metro john just rejected
because it's constructing non-coplana
polygon
okay
i roll but i mean this should work right
we agree this should work
well i think yeah special point date i
think it did accept
entities you know and it was no it does
it seems to it seems to accept entities
but for some reason europe is not flat
enough for it
[Music]
could you just save this so we can you
know calmly look through what the heck
is going on there it's just like yeah i
am saving it
okay
wow
that's pretty spectacular
and kristin will give you the the
material from this
um
okay well there's nothing more to but
but what what does this mean here it
means that that you know let's say that
you know an awful lot of functions in in
geometry
they take a list of points
and now in place of that you can use
spatial point data
nice huh
oh in place of the okay so so for
example if i were to give you let's pick
a spatial point data thing here
um
let's say that you generated a bunch of
uh
yeah i want to generate where do i have
a bunch of special points um
just
give people a chance
okay so here if i say well let's do
spatial point data of two-dimensional
spatial point data here
and then and then i say
voronoi mesh of that
oh why didn't that work that should work
i think
charles
yeah i don't need to double check why um
no idea what's rejecting it now it's
something we need to do
okay all right let's move on but then
treat it as point so that the data in
the point in the spatial point data is
treated as points yes isn't that amazing
yeah well right the way it should be i
mean so so i mean for example i could as
well say here
three and then in principle i can now
say reconstruction mesh of this and so
yes yes okay except it doesn't work
right now for some reason the message is
not found and it's just generally well
the animal is dying
with some you know flailing
characteristics okay all right let's
keep going um
wow
that's exciting
so if i say random graph
of let's say 50 comma 100
okay now what can i do here
so you add the option editable goes to
two
uh what happened here
um you can select the point like in
graphics double click the same has a
graphic so you are moving the whole
graph or you can double click like in
the graphic editor current behavior
come on there you
no there you are changing the bonding
box you have you know there is all the
different state in the graphic editor
okay guys this needs a proper review
this this is not sensible
okay let's get how do i move that point
you select the point and then you move
it you are pitching
okay so there i've got the point
come on
is steven is your selection mode is
exactly the behavior of a graphic when
you i understand which is the wrong
thing
i mean that's why i'm saying this needs
a proper review this is not right you
should not have that be this default
selection mode
because you're going to get this kind of
nonsense when this is not what you want
right help me out how do i select the
point
is that it
oh yeah finally i got the point that's
lovely that's magnificent charles but
let's set it up so that's the default
rather than you know splitting out these
things which is what you want for
graphics editing but not for graph
editing no stephen alice has i mean i
can turn off the dust option but when
you select a point you get the bounding
box so if you stretch the bounding box
you stretch the point
nobody's going to figure this out
nobody's going to figure it out
i i don't just switch it off let's have
an actual review that involves ux people
and let's try and figure this out i also
don't agree that for example this border
not being purple anymore to indicate a
graph isn't right
see what i'm saying
sure
right
let's get a meeting about this as soon
as we can i hopefully it will be
straightforward to just switch on and
off a few options and then we'll have
something wonderful
that makes sense
yep
it's really great that this can be done
um
really great i mean that's another thing
been requested for a long time
i certainly use it all the time how big
a graph can i realistically deal with
uh a bigger girl
any graph size longer we can render it
okay that is also wrong
we are still working on the
you know making the expression back the
whole process
okay fine but but please get a review of
this okay hopefully in the next two or
three days
right so early next week
and make sure we include
design and ux
fair
okay
okay so you think that this will work
basically
if i can manage to somehow miraculously
oh for god's freaking sake
come on
okay so i've got that point now now what
do i do what do i what do i move do i
move
haha it's a joke
come on
tell me how to do this what what am i
trying to click to get to move a point
here
so
you have a point let's take one outside
what no
a little white dot and i've got a purple
dot
okay
then you move it how do i move it what
do i click
so you first have to select the point no
no no no no i've got a selection what do
i do now i've got a selection what do i
what
this selection state was defined by the
graphic that was not no which is wrong
which is not what you want because it's
doing this kind of stupid stuff right
anyway we'll review this separately
okay
okay
spatial graph
distribution that's what i was just
looking at
what does this mean what is
connects
um
if you have notes and they're within a
certain distance they're gonna they're
gonna there's an edge between them so
for instance if you
if they're
like radio transmitters if they're close
enough they can communicate
what is the difference between this and
nearest neighbor graph
what's nearest neighbor graph
this this is a uniform sampling
distribution when nearest graph is a
constructor
is a fixed one
this one we defined early on for random
graphs so in this case you can this
extension is that you can take a disk
for example right
and uniformly you know sample 100 point
on that disk and then connect the one
which are the closest you know oh
nearest neighbor the nearest neighbor in
the graph sense oh no i'm sorry no no
this is spatially you spatially put
points out no no but no no roger look
look
look
i have to go on a second here but but um
um
see this
so here the points are fixed
okay
right so what is
the special graph distribution you
sample so you give the region right
let's suppose you know it's a rectangle
like in the case of you know random real
one two is equivalent to essentially say
spatial graph distribution
right on the rectangle of on the square
zero one
right so you sample the point in that
square
so so you're saying in this case here
that i
say what is i mean i don't understand
10.1.4 white and then you put disk
and you do random
random graph around it
so if i make this like a hundred or
something
there's a beautiful application example
with frogs jumping on lily pads in the
applications
how does this relate to the sprinkling
stuff that's been done
on manifolds
what
i have no idea that's
this is from version nine
no but the fact that well okay hold on
hold on let me look at this for a second
i think this this this relate to
right the interesting curve manifold to
graph right coming from the physics
project
so
this functionality actually cover that
one that
interesting
government uh s transect curve manifold
i think
that one
does it
yep
so
this is
so okay so again we need to make these
connections i mean
well that i mean this was done first so
causality
wasn't exactly we didn't have or what
was it i don't know maybe this just uses
special golf distribution under the hood
right
i mean i think we are planning to put an
application and then you know make the
link with this functional repository if
you want but okay fine that seems useful
okay i mean maybe this just uses spatial
graph distribution underneath
i don't know
you can obviously determine that
um
i mean it's not the hardest function to
write
fair enough well anyway it seems i
understand i was just trying to make my
cognitive connection to understand what
the heck this thing is
makes sense
um i know you have to go to source
now how does this do in terms of the
calculus of annotations
um at this time we don't yet support the
calculation session
it's something we progressively
propagate with the system it's expensive
we take time
so this is
based on the actual names of the
vertices this combines them is that
correct
yes
actually based on the index vertex yeah
vertex list the order in the vertex list
because the sum is based on the sum of a
of matrices
i think
i don't know these definitions but i
mean so that means that if i i don't
quite understand that i mean it's if i
have a b and c and one of these graphs
lacks
b for example i can't do this sparsely i
have to do it with the dense
representation in terms of the sequence
of indices
right or pretty much we extended this
yeah essentially we work on the indices
ordering so
it doesn't matter even if you have you
know abc and c and then you know one two
three four well yeah graph union does
the thing that i'm describing is that
correct if i have graphs what's that
yes graph union does
you take into account the explicit
vertex right
right right right but
i this name seems confusing to me
because this is
go ahead well this is this the standard
name in the nomenclature why people
define it have some graph union have
this trained union product okay but
graph union is doing something different
it's using the actual
you know vertex names of the graph
whereas this is using the vertex indices
yep right yes so it's essentially is the
literature or not or does the literature
is literature blind to whether you're
using names or indices
it's pretty much blind i mean there is
always that in general what people
actually manipulate it you know
on label graph where you know in the
language you're actually dealing with
calf with labels right
so you know sometimes you have to
consult both concepts right listen i
really need to go um so
uh let me just look here
um
we have another
design a catch-up design meeting at um
uh 5 30 eastern today
could we could we add in a few of these
a little loose ends to that if possible
okay that's that's an issue for okay i
need corey recording
yes and and if we can get some ux folk
there we can talk about this graph um
uh the the
um i don't think we'll be able to get
through all this
in 30 minutes just don't think so okay
well
fine and the characters and algebra
stuff too
then we'll have to reschedule for for
monday yeah
okay
this is really good we're really close
but i really need to run okay